all right everyone welcome to the ddps
seminar uh before we introduce um our
invited speaker let's go over some rules
and logistics today uh first of all
please
view yourself during the talk unless you
have questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
unmute and ask otherwise please use chat
room to post your questions so that you
can address them in q a
at the end
second today's ddps seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no class by
discussion is allowed so please watch
out
uh finally the talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our youtube
channel that's about it now now let me
introduce our speaker today it is an
honor to host uh petrus
umuchakus who is a herbert
vinokur a junior professor of the
engineering and applied science faculty
director director of the institute of
applied computational science
and department of
chair of applied mathematics at harvard
university
he studied naval architecture for his
master's degree at university of
michigan
aeronautics and applied mathematics for
phd at caltech
and has served as the chair of
computational science and
eth juric from
1997 to 2020
petrus is elected fellow of the american
society of mechanical engineering
the the american physics society and
the society of industry industrial and
applied mathematics
is recipient of the advanced uh
investigator award by the european uh
research council
and the acm golden bell prize
in
computing
he is elected international member to
the u.s national academy of engineering
his research interests are on the
fundamentals and applications of
computing and artificial intelligence
to understand predict and optimize fluid
flows in engineering nanotechnology and
medicine
today patrols will give a talk about
artificial intelligence and scientific
computing for fluid mechanics now
without further ado let me pass the
button to petrus by asking our usual
questions
uh the question is what is your favorite
things to do during the weekend
working these days it's my favorite
thing oh even during the day if i have
to answer something else let's say uh
photography i like to take pictures
oh that's awesome all right that sounds
fun okay the stage is yours petrus thank
you thank you very much
and thank you very much for having me i
i have great memories uh about my
collaborations with colleagues from
lawrence livermore national lab because
it's uh together uh with people from
ll nl that we won the gordon bell prize
that you mentioned back in 2013.
so
um so i'm going to tell you actually
some of the
adventures that i have had over the last
few decades on on the interface of
artificial intelligence and scientific
computing
and the playground that i have been
having is fluid mechanics but you will
see
perhaps applications in some other
domains
i'd like to acknowledge the people who
have been instrumental uh in this work
now they're
in different uh places uh and times of
their lives but they have been uh very
much instrumental to all the things that
i will be presenting um uh here
so um so talking about computers uh
these are some of the computers that i
had the chance to um to
work on over the
um time that i started i started back in
1981 that's when i went to enter the
university in athens greece and these
are some of the
latest uh computers that we had the
chance to do some of our computations
and the interesting thing here is that
there is a tremendous amount of
increase in
performance that i
a ballpark figure can be in the order of
1 trillion x between
the vox the digital wax machine that i
had back then and what is perhaps today
the number one
supercomputer in the top 500. um so we
have been using uh this
these machines and and here is actually
the simulations that
were
responsible for the gordon bell prize in
super computing in 2013
and and this was done actually with some
uh colleagues uh scott uh fertile and
and um i i think um
uh schmidt and i know not
and and birds and futral were people
that they were from lawrence livermore
so these were simulations that um
ended up improving
uh the time to solution for compressible
flows by
a factor of 30 we were some of the
perhaps first people who ended up doing
petaflops
and are reaching very high percentage of
peak back then in 2013. the simulations
at that time they used about
um 13 trillion
computational elements
and then we had also a compression using
some
wavelet
type of compression which was 10 to 100
x so there was
very heavy computations and then in 2015
we conducted
another computation this time we were
interested in flow of blood at sub
micron resolution in millimeter long
devices and here you see
some of the blood cells this is not the
biggest simulation that we did
but here this was another method this
was not
finite volume as it was in the previous
case now this was a particle method
dissipative particle dynamics
and then we were trying to find
uh circulating uh tumor cells
and then again another record there were
about 13 trillion particles uh there
were tens of millions of time steps and
then we were resolving about 1.4 billion
rbcs
and 0.3 milliliters of blood this was
already
seven years ago i think there's a lot of
other things that people do
over the
years with simulations
uh but the thing that i have learned
from all these uh simulations is that
the
physics based models and the
computations that we do they are
very very useful but at the same time
sometimes you may pay a heavy
computational
price they can be very expensive
so this is some of the computations that
people like myself have been doing in
scientific computing but the general
public perhaps became aware of the power
of computers when computers started to
beat humans in more human-like endeavors
like beating humans in the game of chess
in the game of go and even in in the
game of
poker and of course there is all these
activities that are taking place about
um artificial intelligence is everywhere
particular techniques like reinforcement
learning
you find um every every month you find
either the cover of a famous journal or
something in twitter that gets
uh thousands of likes and and retweets
um
so so there is a lot of excitement of
how people are using computers uh for
artificial intelligence
so
now what is artificial intelligence um
so there is a whole bunch of different
um
approaches on and definitions and i like
one of the definitions that was given by
bellman back in 1978
where he was talking about the
automation of activities
that we associate with human thinking
like playing a game activities such as
decision making problem solving and
learning and there is also another um
definition that i like even more and
this is a definition by
john mccarthy um the idea is that
intelligence is the computational part
of the ability to achieve goals in the
world um so so this computational
ability to achieve uh specific uh goals
and the interesting thing
is that um here the system is most
usefully understood predicted and
control in terms of outcome uh rather
than its mechanisms so in a sense what
this definition says you don't
necessarily need to know everything
about a particular system to understand
whether it is intelligent but you see
what the system is is producing what is
the outcome and then um that's a more
useful understanding about a particular
system so i will come back to these two
um definitions
so in a sense we have two different
types of computing um so in the things
that we do in scientific computing we
take equations and then we translate
them into code and then we use the
computer to execute our instructions
about exactly what should be done and
now uh when you are um doing ai what you
do is going to track the computer to
achieve our goals
so what is the
goals that we have is we have goals like
optimization so i will try to show you
how we can use
learning to do optimization i will
discuss how we can do learning for
dimensionality reduction
uh i will make a small foray into a
learning to control and then i'd like to
show you some more recent work about
learning to predict and in particular
i'll talk about predicting
faster and um and better
so what does it mean learning to
optimize
the problems that we are looking at if
you follow this idea again of artificial
intelligence that you are caring more
about outcomes than about mechanisms the
idea is that you have a system that has
particular mechanisms but what you do is
you have an input x and then you are
observing the output of the system so
that's a black box scenario as we
usually call it so what you have is you
have some data
that you are receiving from the system
after you're producing
a certain input so this can be in fluid
mechanics when you don't have gradients
or the gradients are not so useful uh
you may have a black box solver you may
have experimental setups and also in
cases that you have multiple local
minima and noisy outputs
so how can you learn to solve such
problems well the idea um here is to do
an estimation of a probability
distribution
of um
of the points that contain the optimal
solution uh this formulation date back
to genetic algorithms and evolution
algorithms but with a new twist the idea
is you have some parameters uh that you
are encoding in some let's say an
initial vector of parameters that we
call it parents and then you have some
parameters these parameters define a
probability distribution and you have to
find out these parameters of the
probability distribution as you are
collecting
data and then when you're collecting
data and you're sampling this
probability distribution the cost
function that you have determines what
should be the offsprings of this
evolutionary algorithm what is it that
you don't know you don't know how to
estimate
what is the unknown
the cracks of the matter is what is this
probability distribution these are
stochastic algorithms because you need a
lot of iterations and a lot of data to
estimate the probability distribution of
the optimal points
this is the the function um that uh that
is your black box and very often uh
you're dealing with expensive cons
functions so here we're learning
probability distributions of the optimal
points and here uh we were learning
metamodels to replace expensive
evaluations in the selection process
so this is work that we did almost now
20 years ago where we came up with a
formulation of how to learn probability
distributions and how to integrate
metamodels together
uh with the way of learning uh
probability distributions
so one of the most powerful methods of
estimating probability distributions is
a technique called covariance matrix
adaptation that i'd like to show you so
imagine that um you're trying to
minimize the function f of x
uh this is this is the function that you
have and then you start in with a guess
of a probability distribution that's a
gaussian so you have a mean and you have
a covariance and then what you do is
you're sampling this probability
distribution and then you are collecting
let's say lambda new points these are
the points that you see
here
now what you do is you discard the
points that they have low thickness
that's where your cost function comes
into play
and then you sort and you weigh the
points that you have according to the
fitness you see here the size of the
circle
changes depending on the cost function
then you recombine
the points the good points that you have
obtained and now what you have is you
have actually a way of updating uh the
covariance matrix that you initially
started because now you start to have a
path inside the parameter space in a
sense you can see it as starting to do a
principal component analysis of the
optimal points and that's actually how
you construct the covariance matrix this
technique was originally developed by
nico hansen
who was a postdoc on our lab but this is
technique that he developed when he was
in berlin
our contribution if you like was that i
thought that you can get information not
only by doing this rank one update where
you are doing only a pca between the
mean points but you can also use all the
points that you have between different
generations and in this way you have a
more general
update of the covariance matrix so it's
covariance matrix adaptation because you
sample probability distribution and you
are learning a covariance matrix on the
fly
so the the technique um uh so it's an
it's a it's a it's an iterative
technique uh it's a parallelizable and
and it has all sorts of good things and
it has been used in in many things it
can be used in simulation but it has
also been used in in real experiments
optimizing uh formula one cars
optimizing uh fuel injection rates in
turbo machinery and and many many
applications by ourselves and also
there's a whole bunch of um different
people that are using cmas i remember
when i first got here i was talking to
my colleague katya bertoldi who told me
you know there is this great
optimization method that i found in a
software package and
and we are using it and it's called cmas
and you should try it and
and and i told here i have tried this
method uh and and also there's other
colleagues that are using cmas not only
to do things in a computer but also to
do things in in in the lab so for
example here mori has been using it to
teach
a fin to swim properly and and he has
learned that using an evolutionary
algorithm
another thing that i had done i had
worked
that's actually how i started neural
nets and machine learning proper i was a
postdoc at ctr and i took a course on
computational psychology with david
rumelhart of the backpropagation
algorithm
and the interesting thing was back then
we're talking about 25 years ago that
was the time that in fluid mechanics if
you want to do dimensionality reduction
you have to do the proper orthogonal
decomposition proper orthogonal the
composition is you get the data you form
a covariance matrix and you look at
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
you retain the ones that you like and
then that's what you have the question
is what if you don't like what you got
and what if this linear process how can
you take this linear process and make it
non-linear so that's the time that i
came across neural networks and the idea
is that you can write equivalently
a neural net something that we know
perhaps today as an autoencoder where
you can learn the weights of a network
that learned the identity
mapping and then there was this
beautiful paper by my colleague pierre
baldi and kurt hornick um
that that actually they proved that you
can you can show in one to one
correspondence between these neural nets
and what happens
um uh with the pod and the nice thing
about that is that they can of course
take now the linear things and make it
non-linear by using this principle of
architecture
so instead of going into mathematics and
doing algebra and things like that you
go into architectures and you're
changing
the weights
so what we what i was interested at that
time was interested of wall turbulence
control um so so here um you're seeing a
flow uh above a wall in the channel flow
and then uh what you see uh you're
looking at different ejection light like
events and what i was interested at that
time can i
reconstruct this flow um
by using only information uh from the
wall um so at that time actually uh by
accident we were trying to do the
reconstruction and to compare first of
all for any type of a vorticity field
the original vorticity field
what you can do with a pod
and then you could compare
linear pod with neural nets because you
had a one-to-one
thing on the amount of weights that you
were using except that with the neural
nets you could make them non-linear and
you could make a lot better
reconstruction and i referenced that
because at that time actually by
accident we did some of the first
calculations using deep
neural nets we kept adding layers until
we got a good solution
the other thing which was quite a lesson
that i learned all along and i want to
convey the lesson
is we were trying to reconstruct the
flow above the wall this is the u-plus
and this is the y-plus of a turbulent
channel flow and we were trying to
reconstruct it using wall-only
information so the idea is what if i
give
pressure and vorticity on the wall can i
reconstruct the flow above the wall
the answer to that was a miserable no
and then at some point i realized what
if i help
the neural net and what if i tell them
that to reconstruct
the streamwise velocity along the wall
it's good if you know the um velocity
the vorticity the span wise vertices in
the wall because that depends linearly
uh with the distance above the wall and
also the second derivative of the
velocity actually you can relate it to
the vorticity flux and in terms of the
pressure gradient so you help the neural
net by telling it what the first two
terms in the polynomial should be and
then we gave to the neural net to do the
rest of the work
so the solid line is an average velocity
profile that we got from a dns and this
is what maybe uh you would get actually
this is what you would get by doing a
linear pod and then when you take the
second or reconstruction here and put
together with a neural net
you will get dust dot that was a much
better reconstruction and if you were
using only the second order you already
had y class of three or or or uh or four
you already lose uh the accuracy and
here you see actually that the neural
net does help you to advance for for for
a little bit of time
so at that time i remember i i was very
excited about machine learning i even
wrote a review article about machine
language flow modeling and optimization
that nobody wanted to publish
except the annual research briefs of ctr
from 1999
and one of the reasons that actually
this research at that time was quite
problematic was if you look at how
computers evolved i wrote another review
article about machine learning for fluid
mechanics more recently
the speed up of the computer tells the
whole story what takes about three
minutes in 2019 to compute it would have
taken about a year in 1997. so so that's
a big big
difference
now learning to predict um so so
more recent work uh i was interested in
looking at different types of data i was
interested in data that are coming out
of time series so i thought i would look
into recurrent neural nets and long
short-term memory
networks and try to see how can i use
lstm serie car and neural nets in order
to predict complex systems as a matter
of fact i was first introduced to
lstms when i moved to switzerland in
1997 because i got to know jurgen
smithhuber
who was the inventor of lstms and we
actually together wrote a proposal um to
get some money from the swiss national
science foundation about using machine
learning from fluid mechanics back then
and and it was promptly rejected but
that's what it is um
in any case uh
so so now this is what we do um
so we i'll show you some examples some
predictions for the kuramoto zivazinski
so here's the kuramoto shivasinsky
we can discretize it with a finite
different scheme and the question is can
i train a little bit and then try to
predict uh using only recurrent neural
nets and forgetting
about
the equation
so
the training data we could choose they
could be high dimensional data we have
all the information we want by solving
um the kuramoto uh sivasinski but then
we thought if we want to have something
more practical we might as well project
the high dimensional data to a low
dimensional space and the initial
work that we did was to actually project
it uh using the svd uh proper orthogonal
decomposition pca whatever you want to
call it
so training data are no longer the full
description of the
of the of the kuramoto swazinsky but we
kept 20 svd modes because this were
giving us enough of the total energy for
a particular viscosity so this was
actually um the lower dimensional state
and actually this helped us to have
easier training because of the memory
requirements of the lstm
so how good is this
um so how good is this and let me show
you some results so here is the some
particular case of the kuramoto
shivacinski and we are using data in
this green square so we're taking data
in this green square and after i'm
training in this green square i want to
see what if i switch off after that my
training and then i no longer solve
kuramoto shibazinski but i'm using my
lstm to predict what's happening further
okay important is this i don't want to
interpolate i want to extrapolate i want
to predict beyond my domain that i have
here so how good are lstms um well
when you look right after the training
you seem to be getting a very good
solution
if you move it to about 0.5 of the
training that you have done um it still
works quite well
you move it to one time unit where one
time unit is where you were training you
start to see some problems and the
system is chaotic as soon as you start
to have problems when you try to look at
what happens further you're going to
lose it so we find that we can predict
for some time but we cannot
forget about the equation because at
some point we start to run away from the
equation itself no matter what successes
that we may have
so if you want to see uh the forecasting
error that we make um you see
that as the time progresses we make
higher and higher forecasting error in
the modes where we have done the
training and also in the
reconstruction
so our result was that for some systems
you can predict them up to a certain
time it depends very much on the
chaoticity of the system but the
recurrent neural nets and other neural
nets that we used are not the solution
to predict uh uh complex systems and and
and i'll show you uh the effect of
chaoticity so remember the kuramoto
silvacinsky has a coefficient that
multiplies the fourth order term this is
the prediction are the blue points the
true
is the green and you see that you slowly
as you start to depart
from a green then the system is chaotic
but you keep it there for a while but
eventually you start to predict uh very
different uh things and here maybe you
can say i have remained within the limit
within the phase space you see the
things don't go wild but when you
reduce the dissipation um and then you
start to see that you get some really
wild uh discrepancies and and the
systems um
uh don't don't seem to be doing a good
job so we're very uh surprised when we
saw a paper in quantum magazine that
said actually that our work along with
other works show that machine learning
has an amazing ability to predict chaos
and all i want to say about that that
this paper show you that machine
learning does not perhaps it does not
yet uh but definitely i think
we have to be careful and i think there
is exciting times to try to
see whether uh machine learning can
predict um
uh chaotic and complex uh systems
so so let's say
we have problems in trying to predict
with machine learning alone can we
combine now machine learning uh together
with some of the things we do
in scientific computing so the first
thing i want to show you is how can we
learn to predict but
accelerating what scientific computing
can do
so i i i'm trying to be fancy and i'm
saying that what i'm doing are alloys
alloys of scientific computing and ai so
same way as you may have
two metals and and then you can replace
one metal with another
or you can intersperse
some some metal inside the other metal
or you can do all of the above you may
think that you can have models and
numerics and you may have
machine learning tools
that you are combining and i call this
computing alloys
so let me show you the first alloy and
the first alloy
it's the idea of learning the effective
dynamics of complex systems
so this idea is traced back to a
person that actually was one of the
pioneers in machine learning
and i think he worked even before myself
in this field this is yanis kevrakidis
and janis had this wonderful idea of
equation free framework the idea was
that you do some simulations in the
microscales but because you are
running into an expensive code you
cannot afford to run for a long time so
what if you just filter it and you go to
a macro scale and then you advance onto
the microscale using some kind of an
integrator
and now you cannot afford to stay the
whole time on the micro scale point but
then you need to return into the micro
scale that's the lifting operator and
then you iterate
so i always had this idea in my mind
actually yanis introduced me to this
idea when he first came up with it in a
visit that he just had a dth uh but i
always there were two things i didn't
like i didn't like the way um the
time propagation was done using standard
finite standard schemes like roon ke
kuta and things like that and i was
always puzzled how do you go from the
macro back onto the micro from less
information to more information
so after spending a lot of time uh
traveling around machine learning ideas
i i thought that you know what uh we
have auto encoders and what the auto
encoders do not only they learn how to
go to the latin space but they also
learn how to go back out to the full
space so when you're doing the training
of an auto encoder you're learning to go
to the filter space and you go you use
the decoder to go back out into
the full space and from what you saw i
know how to integrate um
reduced order spaces using long
short-term memory recurrent networks so
what if we put these two things together
so i have a macro dynamic propagation as
i just showed you but i go back and
forth between my simulation using uh
restricting and lifting using auto
encoders
so what's the idea the idea now is like
that you have some simulations and then
you use the encoder decoder to figure
out a lot in space and then you evolve
into the latin space using memory and
rnns and then whenever you need to go
out you use a decoder
then you evolve again you update your
encoder and decoder and you go back and
forth and you may see that there is
actually two time scales that you have
to uh take into account there is a micro
scale t mu and a macro scale tm
and then you can play with these two
different scales in order to decide how
much you can or you want to accelerate
so how good is this back to kuramoto
sivasinski
what we find is that here is the
reference solution
and the interesting thing that we uh
also found on the way is that if you
want to do effective dynamics uh there
is a paper that showed that effective
dynamics of kuramoto shivasinsky lie on
an eight-dimensional uh manifold
and the interesting thing that we found
actually is that when we use an auto
encoder to uh process each one of the
snapshots in time or the kuramoto
civacinski the autoencoder is actually
magically saturate after
eight and then we use two different auto
encoders and both of them seem to be
doing a good job in figuring out this
number eight that people uh uh robust on
it i'll have seen before to be uh the
truth and then you see if you do the bad
thing you use a pod or another
compressing thing
you may be
you may be off this magic number of
eight so you have to be careful how do
you go to the latin space
now how well the lead works so here's
how the latin space is evolving and
here's what the led does you see that we
don't get a one-to-one correspondence
but if you look at the phase space of
the two derivatives the first and the
second derivative of the u you find out
that you're actually doing a pretty good
job and the the interesting thing is to
look at the
speed up that you may get so if you stay
only uh on the latin space you can have
a hundred uh
factor of of speed up um so you don't
actually need to ever go back
to um
to the full space if you're doing the
right uh compression that's what this
message is but you can also place uh
with a speed up and you have some minor
improvement on the on the
we tried it also in a cylinder um this
is flo reynolds number of a hundred
and then we found actually that uh we
are able to do a pretty good prediction
uh we get a speed up of a factor of of
we find actually much better convergence
in term of the error and not only we get
convergence in term of the error of the
vorticity but if you look at quantities
like the drug
you can do a simulation 100 times faster
and
you can capture the drag to within 5 4
but of course this is reynolds number of
100 and a lot of people say here i've
done reynolds number of 100 the rest is
trivial well the rest is not trivial
because at least for us when we do
reynolds number of a thousand
we don't find that we have such good uh
error with this led we actually stop and
we have uh things like 20 of the error
um and and and what we figure out
actually is not only the auto encoder
that you're using but also what are the
points that you're using in order to do
the compression so we know that
vorticity happens around the surface of
the cylinder so what we learned from
that is actually that when you
pick or give higher weight in your auto
encoder to points where the physics are
dominant that's when the autoencoder
starts to behave
better
we applied this also in molecular system
is a very general framework
uh
so here is the alanine d peptide this is
a phase diagram of alanine two peptide
and then if you do a molecular
simulation you
find that you are this is the phase
space that the molecular dynamics can
simulate
and then what you can do is you can
apply
the led and then we're using a latin
space of one dimension
uh
and and then what the led gives you
actually you see that you get an a latin
space
that looks like a free energy type of a
projection that has various minima and
indeed these various minima they
correspond to the different places where
the molecular dynamic simulations have
been spending their time at the same
time
uh i always want to mention that for
good results you also have bad results
but results is that we capture some
areas but some other areas that they
were not in the the training set and we
never visited this part of the domain we
are not able to capture as for example
this area ael we don't capture it very
well c7 you can say c7 ax as we call it
we are pretty much
okay but there is a lot of promise uh
we're working on on this thing and and
we hope to have a better results and
better theory on the future
now one more thing one more recent work
is about learning to predict not only
not faster but try to predict better and
i will explain
what i mean that but first i'd like to
tell you
um that prediction is like control
so better prediction
means control prediction to achieve your
goals under certain
energy or cost constraints
so let me introduce you to
the topic of control and the idea here
is that i'm trying to combine scientific
computing and multi-agent reinforcement
learning
what is reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is the situation
where you have some kind of a behavior
of an agent
a human a computer whatever you want uh
where
the
the agent is performing uh
an action it receives a stimulus and a
reward from the environment and then um
as the reward is accumulating then the
agent is conditioned to a particular
behavior
one of the pioneers of that was actually
here at harvard was
a person called buru
toward him and skinner it toward the
other pigeon
which infects the ball back across the
table if it goes past one pigeon the
other pigeon can eat and
did you need so there's a real surreal
game
so so you see that the pigeons actually
learn uh they reinforce the particular
behavior and the idea was actually to
put pigeons inside
inside rockets and and then you
have some windows there and then the
pigeons they look out and then whenever
they see a particular landscape then
they will uh punch a button and then a
bomb will fall out and and uh
and and then hit the target and this was
the reason behind this work uh there's a
beautiful uh article um pigeon pilots
that i would recommend because it shows
you some of the pioneering works in
reinforcement learning but with animals
of course reinforcement learning has
been very popular in um in in games um
so
all these successes of artificial
intelligence there's a lot of
reinforcement learning behind so what's
reinforcement learning uh reinforcement
learning is that you basically if you
remember when i do stochastic
optimization i had a covariance matrix
that i am adopting well again you're
adopting uh you have a gaussian
probability distribution with a mean and
a covariance if you like but now the way
you update the mean and the covariance
is by playing again again where you're
observing states the states are going
through a particular interpolator here
we have a recurrent neural network that
has weights and then the weights are
changed by observing the expectation of
the long-term reward of what you um uh
of of of what you do so you basically
have an expectation condition or
something that we call a policy the
policy has the weight the weights are
being changed and as you are acting you
have this loop that tells you how to
change the the weight in order to
maximize your your reward
um why is this good for control um i i
in flow control i'm i always found
fascinating that you have the governing
equations but usually things that you
are controlling with let's say
deformations on the surface they don't
necessarily appear in an explicit way
into the cost function that you want to
control so for example if you want to
control the drag you have the
navier-stokes equations and even if you
can add the controller on the navier
structure equations for the drag is a
byproduct so it's not so trivial to do
derivatives or at least myself i didn't
know how to do it well
so i found that reinforcement learning
may overcome some of these challenges
now reinforcement has the challenges
itself the idea is that you play many
many many games in order to figure out
finally what is the right policy and one
of the popular techniques that people do
in reinforcement learning is something
called off policy learning
the idea of of policy learning is that
as you try right now to make a policy
about what you do you look at what you
have done in the past and then you say
which one of the experiences i have the
past are most relevant for me to achieve
a goal uh
now
so this experience play and and one of
the notorious things about uh experience
we play is that it is uh relatively
unstable uh and people have stand spent
a lot of time trying to stabilize
uh this process and actually when we
looked at it we found out that the key
thing was that basically experience
replay amounts to important something
so what do we mean by that again here is
the policy that you are looking for in
order to maximize your reward
and then what you do is
you are collecting experiences and at
some point you want to bring back some
of these experiences to inform the
action that the agent is taking so
again there is this instability that i
mentioned and and the way to to see this
is that you're taking an expectation in
terms of one policy but then you want to
decide that you're going to change the
expectation you're going to change the
expectation in terms of another policy
so this is the experiences that you have
so the policy to update and the old
policy that you're using sometimes they
are may not be
at the same location so you may blow up
and also the two probability
distributions between the online policy
and the old policy they may be very
dissimilar and as you know in important
sampling
it's when you do important sampling if
the two probability distribution are not
similar you are off
so we spent uh some time and and with my
student guido novati now works in deep
mind we came up with this algorithm
remember and forget experience replay
where we try to fix uh these two things
now
um we were very surprised actually the
the story here is very different than
doing neural nets and taking tensorflow
and running if you take um algorithms
that you find on the internet and you
applying them in fluid mechanics
problems here's a fluid mechanic front
we're trying to control a disk
behind a cylinder we never found any of
these algorithms to work
and also we were very surprised that
when we took our algorithm and we
compared with reinforcement learning
algorithms that people used to do mujoko
and all these games that they do we were
much better in terms of reward so there
are some accommodations that you need to
do but um so there is it's important to
work on this uh on these topics
so one of the things we did is uh is we
worked we were very interested to use
reinforcement learning to study
schooling
so schooling is when fish stream
together there's different ideas that uh
the school uh may have different
benefits uh now when you do it in the
when you observe it in the in the lab
the fish they're doing something
themselves but now when you go to the
computer
and you put some swimmers and you give
them an initial uh velocity if you don't
do adaptive control
then what happens is the swimmers
because of the flow structure
interaction they're going to start to
collide
so before we are able to study schooling
we have to make these guys to school of
course it's easy to make them school by
forgetting about navier stokes equations
and putting some rules but if you put
navier stokes equations and you do flow
structure interaction it's a very
difficult control problem
so we solve this problem by doing
reinforcement learning we have a swimmer
that observes certain states i'm not
gonna go and discuss that and then
observe has different actions and
receives a reward we can decide on
different rewards
so here the reward for this swimmer was
we asked the swimmer to swim right
behind
um the other um the other fish
and then when we
saw that when we did that we found
actually that the swimmer that was in
the wake we're using much
less energy than the streamer in the
front
so we said okay that's that's very
interesting um
what if we ask actually the
uh the the swimmer um so it was about 12
percent better what if we ask the
swimmer to optimize for efficiency
so we got
another pattern which is wonderful
because we found a very beautiful ballet
between vertices and the head of the
swimmer how it intercepts vortices so to
gain energy from them and we got
actually a pretty good efficiency of
about a gain of about 28
percent
we applied this thing in in 3d
um with different uh configurations so
again these are big simulations using
wavelet adapted grids vortex methods
which are the things that i was doing
um viscous vortex methods that are
accurate and and
using
control through
reinforcement
learning and again this is a simulation
that we are driving to where here i have
300 fish so again we're going to big
super computers again
and here they have not learned anything
so they're swimming left and right
but we hope to add um some learning
algorithms to them to make them uh
school
and also here is also talking about the
blood we didn't forget the blood so here
is a
bacteria that learns
through a magnetic field to travel in
certain places and to target
different cells
so now all this is good for control but
how about for prediction
so now there is a relationship between
prediction and control and this
relationship is the following
usually when we have a system what we do
is we
we can break
the
unknown into things that we can observe
we can resolve on a grid a u bar and
things we cannot observe on a grid a u
prime
and then when you do this decomposition
uh this is reynolds leveraging for
navier stokes um you get something like
that where you have to come up with a
model
that is in terms of the average
quantities uh and then you have to
supply this model in order to do provide
the closure to the equation so it's a
pretty
general thing it can happen to les it
can be coarse grain molecular dynamics
so inspired from control um i thought
what if we use reinforcement learning to
do that what if i learn uh the closure
models using reinforcement
there is a lot of work that has been
done about supervoice supervised
learning and and
and
turbulence modelling i will not refer to
that uh i think there are certain
advantages of the reinforcement lending
first of all reinforcement learning the
way we use it in the multi-agent way is
very much data efficient
so i will explain what i mean by that so
you're having a grid and on the grid
you're solving equations
so you can take your navier stoves you
solve them on the grid and at the same
time you can disperse on the grid agents
and now these agents you can have one to
one with a grid and they can learn now
how to behave so that they provide
closures for the equations that are
being solved on the grid
so this is the scientific multi-agent
reinforcement learning
we have
published this work about a couple of
years ago
to do turbulence modeling using mars and
and i'll show you a little bit
okay you all know what homogeneous so
here's here's what we do so here is a
homogeneous turbulence and
what we are asking uh is we are asking
that we have agents throughout the
domain
now the agents they have some local
states you can imagine that if i had one
agent and a big policy and then i was
asking for states to be my whole domain
then let's say even if i do a 32 cube
grid
and i observe every velocity i will have
3 times 32 to the cube states and that's
a lot
it would be impossible to to run
reinforcement learning at least with the
resources we have so instead we said
what if i have some global
states that i can get
energy for example of of my system and
look at the fourier modes and what if i
look at the invariance of my
gradient tensor and the laplacian
temperature so
the states that you choose actually make
it or break it and then in the end what
the agent learns it learns this
turbulence coefficient and the reward is
how do you recover things that you do
from a dns
so um so here are some results
so there are different ways that we have
our policy different rewards focus on
the blue points for a moment the blue
lines so here i have trained my
reinforcement learning on this adi
lambda 65 140 163 and then you can see
that i go and i try to predict in
between but i also go and i try to
predict far away to extrapolate into
things that were not within this 163 so
190 and 205 were way beyond that and
what you see from this blue policy which
is basically using a reward that depends
on the energy spectra is pretty much
recovering
the
black line on the energy spectrum you
see here how the dynamics magorinsky
model and the standards magoski that are
known to be to be relatively well they
don't perform as well as this blue uh
policy is behaving the yellow one is we
said what if i train on only one
reynolds number how good i am in all the
other reynolds numbers so you see that
you're still doing better that standard
smargorinsky and the red one this is a
case where for example there is failure
because here the reward was observing
the german identity and then we found
that this reward actually was not very
good to give you uh recapturing of of
the energy
more recent work that i will not
elaborate today this was work with jane
bye that was recently appeared in nature
communications um i would not tell you
about the states of and the actions so
that we state we stay
within the time
but what um let me
go to uh the the results um so so what i
had
is i trained um my um
multi-agent reinforcement uh learning
algorithm
uh by receiving um uh
some
estimates of the of certain quantities
in the near wall region and and then
what i'm doing is i am acting by tuning
the the shear stresses that i are
applying on on on on my
on my on my turbulent uh channel flow
and and then um so here is the test that
i did so we tested the we trained the
algorithm up to rainless number of 10 to
the four retau and then we try to see
how well does it extrapolate
we found that it's able to capture
the mean
shear velocity pretty well and we know
what is the correct thing because we
know the pressure gradients that we have
uh in the flow and and this is the
recovery on the different places in the
domain of the law of the wall the law of
the wall is what it should have
recovered and you see how well it
recovers over a wide range of re uh tao
and then we took training that has been
done in the turbulent channel flow and
we applied it in a turbulent boundary
layer and then we were very happy to see
that we can actually recover
experimental results of the
friction coefficient without retraining
or a turbulent boundary layer
so i have presented you some alloys of
scientific computer machine learning
there can be data
and equation driven
they are trying to overcome
uh certain computational barriers and
certain things that we know about
closures
nothing is perfect in what we do we
would like to have more theory
uh we are exploring uh different ideas
uh between advanced machine learning
algorithms and how
they play together with things that we
do in scientific computing and we are
investigating a whole bunch of
of different applications
uh it's an exciting time i would like to
insist
that uh neither uh scientific computing
alone i think can go on
ignoring ai and i think ai cannot go
along with uh on at least on some of the
problems we tackle with scientific
computing by ignoring all these other
things that we have developed over the
years and in particular i'd like to
argue the physics knowledge is extremely
important for enforcement learning if
you don't pick
the correct states you're never going to
get the algorithm to work i can show you
an infinite amount of wrong results
because we didn't pick uh
the right states
um i'd like to thank you and i'll be
happy to take any questions that you may
have
thank you thank you so much for the
action the beautiful talk um i mean i i
think it's it was the one of the most
beautiful toy i ever seen actually
uh thank you so much uh let's have a uh
q a sessions um if you have
any questions please
i guess some mute yourself and then
speak direct ask directly
to start i guess i can ask
questions and
as you have uh briefly mentions you know
you know you know the training that
you're the reinforcement learning or the
other types of neural nets in your um
various projects you have introduced
today
probably you haven't show all the
you know struggles of the training the
neural net um because that's one of the
real bottom line how do you usually
you know the resolve those those
struggles um
so so for the struggle so for example i
can tell you on the reinforcement
learning um you saw that in the
turbulence modeling
uh of the homogeneous turbulence um
maybe i can share again my screen let me
share my screen yeah yeah uh and let me
go to my keynote um
so if if i go back here
you will see
that the states for example that i
picked for my
reinforcement learning
in the homogeneous turbulence they are
not quite obvious
so first of all okay i don't pick my
velocity field
but then i go and i find the
gradient tensor and the laplacian and
then i i i look at the invariance of
these tensors
and um if i had gone and i had picked
just velocity fields this algorithm
doesn't work i could never we could
never get it to produce anything it
would be lost in some
landscape that was very strange now
these invariants are pretty good because
um we you can think about it later
because if you are in homogeneous and
isotropic turbulence these are the
invariants that that you should try to
uh um to to to maintain
um also uh getting the total dissipation
is something that you would like to have
and then we played around with the
energy and then we said what if i look
at the different fourier components of
the energy and let me collect a few of
them a state so it was a trial and error
and and there is a
basically trying to find the manifold of
of where your actions
here the actions were just this
coefficient of the smart gorinsky model
we we we played with all sorts of
different
um
spagorinski models but finally we
decided to stick with that so there was
only one action that you have here every
agent has a local action and
and goes to its neighbors
but all these things are very closely
linked so so your question is is very
deep very fundamental
and i think unless we find a clever
machine learning based way of finding
spaces where these algorithms can be
effective i still maintain that the best
bet that we have at the moment is
physical
understanding about the things that we
try to do
and and these are the things that can
help us to figure out at least for
reinforcement what are the states
and and the actions uh that i uh try to
do
also in the case of the led um yes okay
my auto encoders they're nice and they
bring me down to this reduced order
space
but to me they seem very artificial is
there for me it would be very
interesting if i could figure out
causal latin variables for example the
things that are critical for a flow and
project on these
um dimensions in order to do my led
maybe my error will be reduced reduced
even more
um so i'm a big proponent of of uh of of
keeping to teach people physics
and numerics uh along with machine
learning machine learning is an amazing
set of tools makes you think different
of course of course okay so yeah even
though the um
well
okay so the impression i got from your
answer is that even though you use the
physics well the physics is guiding your
trial and errors and then that's right
that's right what matter is is
unavoidable but the
plan
there are different things that we are
thinking about about how to uh find uh
optimal um
optimal spaces and optimal landscapes uh
but automatically
in an automated fashion and in a machine
learning fashion but
um yeah that's that's a big talk that's
another big talk about that maybe when i
talk again about u2 i'll talk about that
because it involves some kind of by
asian inference that we are using for
that
i see all right sounds good okay any
other question from audience
don't be shy i something
i'll try to answer
yeah amit
okay hi has
so i am interested in the example of
alanine diaper style that you showed
and i was wondering so you are
essentially now able to sample
so to say a free energy landscape
because you were able to force the in
the system
and
[Music]
i wonder if you didn't
use any sampling method to explore
this course in space because you were
showing that
um
the model was unable to explore
um some high energy region so is it
possible to sort of couple this with
some sampling method
and have you done that do you see any
problems including no no but actually it
would be
very interesting to try to use
some of the techniques like metadynamics
and all these kind of things that people
have done
in order to escape
low order regions together with this
framework i think there is a a very
broad array of possibilities of how
once you are done at this latin space to
start to use techniques that people have
been using in molecular dynamics and
other places to try to how do you evolve
in the latin space at the moment i was
doing it in a very mundane way by using
recurring neural nets but
nothing tells me that it should be
recurring well nets it can be something
else
so
again this led paper came out uh
about
two weeks ago after being sent around
for two years um and and we are trying
to to build on it
okay
and i actually have a related question
um after you co-screen the system i know
you showed a lot of results
about uh fluid dynamics but
for an atomic system after you code
screen
i wonder if it is possible to learn the
dynamics
and if you have done that
um like learn the dynamics in the
coaching variable space and then once
you evolve the system for a certain
amount of time you fold it back to the
original
configuration space in this way
one can envision a way to speed up
molecular dynamics about automatically
doing
uh court cleaning also
yes that's that's uh that's another
topic of future work at the moment we
have stayed
we have stayed only in the coarse grain
space and and and since we didn't we
didn't
do the thing of going back and forth and
and replacing the molecular dynamics but
this is actually something that
that uh that we are working on at the
moment the idea is to to try to do
very long time uh molecular dynamic
simulations by by building that but we
have not done that yet
okay yeah we are trying to do something
similar
here
at the lab and perhaps we can talk about
it later i would be
very happy to to exchange uh sure be
happy to talk about that
yeah thank you
thank you
all right so uh there's another uh the
question in q a
uh sean asked oh he said very nice talk
um thank you asked what's your viewpoint
in thinking physics informed neural
networks for modeling complex dynamics
uh it is also a very hot topic in
scientific machine learning
okay i have an answer because i actually
happened to work in physics and form
neural nets a long time ago
i'll tell you what is my experience with
that
uh so i have some slides
awesome on that uh so i i'll show you
what is my experience with physics in
form uh neural nets actually
i call it learning to interpolate
so learning to interpolate means that
you have some equations
and then
here is um what i had um what i can get
and now i'm not talking about
extrapolating i'm talking about
are you sharing the screen oh no okay
sorry
we are not we are not seeing
um share
share
you can see it now so yeah so that's
what i call learning to interpolate
um so you have the neural networks for
for pdes and then the idea here is that
you're using some some points x and t
that's the domain remember the query
model shiva since i was showing you
earlier uh and then this is the um the
loss function that
this these techniques have
these techniques i first encountered
them back in 1998 there's this paper by
uh lagaris and likas and fotiadis that
actually describe and introduce this
method and this was the time i was
playing with neural nets
so i tried
this method and i will show you what are
the results i got back then and that's
the same results that i get back now but
of course um people
don't know lagaris and and likas and
fotiadi so much they come from an
obscure university in ioanna people know
this paper and this paper actually
mentions the paper of lagaries it's
reference
where they're actually saying similar
ideas have existed i think it's the same
ideas i think what is interesting in the
new paper
of the 2019 is that you use tensorflow
and and then
you're doing different things so my
experience is the following um that here
is the kuramoto siddasinski again and
now what i do is i take uh different um
neural networks and i'm using different
networks and different seeds and so on
and so forth and what you find is that i
increase the network size and i'm
varying the seed and i find that
the so-called pins they converge this to
the exact solution
now this is the kuramoto silvacinsky
equation with these parameters now i
change the parameters to the current
motorcycle scheme maybe i make it a
little bit more challenging and and i
never got it to work
so if you have if the problem starts to
become more stiff
and you are looking into longer times
at least myself we find
that the things
they are
they don't converge and not only that
if you look at the
computational intensity
this is there's two things to observe
here so here's the number of parameters
that you may have
uh on a using a finite difference scheme
so you get your classical one over n and
here you can do a whole bunch of
different samples it's interesting that
in some cases you get some samples
actually that they give you the correct
solution but if you do a spectrum of
solutions as you should be doing because
this is a stochastic method you find
that you're all over the place
and and the mean convergence rate is is
like that so of course if i show you
these results one two and this one you
will say okay that's that's really good
but that's not really good when you
change initial conditions and parameters
and the other thing that's for me the
big difference is that these things when
you trade them they cost you a million
times more
than uh finite differences
um i think they are merits to to to
these techniques um
that are worth investigating uh but um
at least uh there is this is my
experience with this
with this method i'm happy to answer
questions
very good very good
is there any other question
okay if not let's um
conclude the talk let's thank our
speaker for the wonderful talk and
thank you for having me yeah and for all
the questions
yeah and
and thank you everyone for joining us uh
with that let's
end
the webinar talk today
okay let me push the stop button